духи вечірка щоб продовжити реакцію
на те, що ми чули від путіна як
людина з одеси я можу сказати що
найбільшою допомогою російськомовним
людям у яких він теж там згадав
будь якщо він забереться з криму забереться
з донбас і залишити нас у спокої в
рамках нашої країни жити і це сама
велика допомога якої він може зробити
тому що насправді путін убив
більше російськомовних людей, ніж хто б то
не було в цьому світі
щоб більша частина з тринадцяти тисяч
загиблих на донбасі вони якраз і
російськомовні люди
він їх вбиває для нього не сміття
сміття ви воді політичних іграх all
ще я хочемо повинен жив назва програма
куди і так путін путін думаючи ширини д-да
на вигляд не і ялти
загалом це win pro c кажи всьому світу
всякий земний
і давайте у справах у дуже мало ліфті і
поділом у цума que de russie я наша зона
у пливу
american via ви знаю китай ok давайте
сядемо і зростаємо розуму за кольором вин жива
від усього 1945 уроком на тему вин
повністю запаяні вся і мета була я в
перші 6 грам я за ми навряд чи не добре
і 45 37 ну і 30 вона 37 in th натиск осіб
олексій навальний припинив голодування
це вже ніби хороша новина і вас
вінда хочете їй але ж не я ти йому
знаєте шо викрутив вимагаючи я думаю що
ми моєму облік розумі тес моменту
твинка байда треба путіна
беру фітнесі збивши підлоги до нуля до них
його саміту їх не саміт виду тисячі
вчорні чохли пні ніж 8000 і бачите
швейцарії олівін вигляд будете і повірте
ми не путін не помічаємо за задоволений і б
знаємо ніхто не збирається розписуватись
ялту і ось з нас будуть нового
повернення на bespeco теж означаючи 1
зустрічаємо в годину не зустрічаємо а пильовик і
70 мама ви росте і максимально щоб
вдаватися оружі не сили українців раз і
для crockid на міжнародній арені я
хочу звернутися доповіді голови доступні
кораловий фракції слава народу
тих рок і включають донатом і
за два місяці на ступах у цінах ожив
його ціна шлях all its і позики годину е1
ричі до я вклав його ціни джона немає або
донатит states основні союзних США поза
межами на ту ви знаєте шини ск окраїн
таки статус травня та україна ми ж вранці
цієї іншої та островів постанову
верховної ради України
свердлимо до американського конгресу з
порох вони їм Петро їм caity lotz статусу та
руку у в'язниці на премію
давайте хоче і перетягнути його я
кварцові дно алли давайте розум і
починається з асей на тиждень
давайте ви до зростання йому civic але доки
україна напишеш пальцях у тому числі в
США і тому cms віч давайте наш
страшний сьогодні брокерський народ з
отримання штати Америки та кеном до
допомагають у хмара сколи тихо вам його стиснув
її братом і ще вчора нам струну і натиснувши
спину
ось c3 обидва нам обов'язково зуби-то я
заклинаю вас дати його